So Leute, ich bin am Start, das ist der fanciest Auf-Close-Screen, den ihr je gesehen habt,
oder? Mehr Auf-Close-Screen geht nicht, das ist Hyper Auf-Close-Screen.
So, genug Auf-Close-Screens. Oh, das kann man ja kaum abbrechen.
Frag mich nicht, was ich hier gerade mache.
Ich warte eigentlich nur, bis der Stream richtig on ist.
So, 35 Zuschauer, jetzt hat Twitch aktualisiert, sehr schön.
Der Stream ist also am Start. Ich mache nochmal einen Twitter-Post.
Ups, Twitter-Post.
5.
Ich streame jetzt irgendwie schon gefühlt den zehnten tag in folge oder so fast in folge
Wo ist der max ja wo ist er weiß ich nicht weißt du es vielleicht
Du hast den letzten stream verpasst was hast du da gemacht also eigentlich haben wir gestern abend
nur irgendwie was spackt mein terminal eigentlich so gestern abend haben wir eigentlich nur
warum ist die frage von moonbeer da nicht drin kaputt starten wir neu wir haben eigentlich nur
dumm rumgeschwätzt ohne großartig was zu machen wir haben uns über alles mögliche haben wir uns
ausgelassen über smarte close über china shops über netzwerk topologie über alles mögliche ja
der stream ist gerade ich bin gerade vor fünf minuten online gekommen
hoffentlich funktioniert das tool jetzt irgendwie als kann ein bisschen rumgespackt
und wollte nicht mehr ich glaube die verbindung zu twitch ist abgekackt
übrigens das das kommando was hier dieses zeugs auf die auf die auf das terminal schreibt wenn
das die falschen leute wenn das die falschen leute entdecken gibt ist die anzeige direkt raus
denn das programm macht ja eigentlich nur text als banner im terminal und das hat allerdings
den kommando minus minus gay und dann macht rainbow wenn das die falschen leute entdecken
dann ist gleich hier der twitter der twitter flame und der kotaku artikel und dann ist alles
raus dass die fall wenn das die falschen leute entdeckten ist echt vorbei das kann man nicht
verwenden tos monka tos ja aber ich monka tos
erst mal die falschen leute liegen ja mittlerweile wird sich ja wirklich aufgeregt
so es gibt jetzt ein paar fragen hier das heißt man guckt mal mein tool jetzt geht das tool wieder
sehr schön mach eine ai für dein frage tool was erkennen kann auch ohne wo plus
nee ich finde es hat irgendwie leicht hypnotische wirkung wenn man sich das im terminal lange
lang genug anguckt oder so lange man sich monka tos anguckt umso mehr monka tos wird man im
hirn ich hatte heute eh schon wieder auf der arbeit oder merkwürdige begegnung ich habe
sie auf twitter geschrieben es hat mir einer erzählt es hat mir einer erzählt dass er
einen parkplatz vorm gebäude bekommen hat nicht aber als anfang gesagt pock alter oder
oder irgendwas in der richtung voll pock glaube ich habe gesagt aber ich habe gesagt pock da
habe ich komisch angeguckt und ich meine normale leute verstehen natürlich nicht was man damit
sagen will weil ich würde mal sagen 99,9 noch ein paar neuner der weltbevölkerung verstehen
wahrscheinlich nicht was ich damit meine aber der twitch chat versteht
so da kann ich heute nämlich mal bei der china einkaufen da war nämlich gestern stehen geblieben
übrigens aliexpress lässt mich seit heute wieder die seite prausen ohne dass ich mich
anmelden muss ich verstehe den sinn ich davon heute grill underwear kriegen wir empfohlen
ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht warum ich mich manchmal bei aliexpress einloggen muss
dass es funktioniert keine ahnung gestern musste ich mich bei aliexpress einloggen heute
muss ich bei aliexpress nicht einloggen ich frage mich was passiert wenn man sich unterwäsche
bei aliexpress kauft kriegt man dann ausschläge oder so davon
mit sicherheit ich glaube ich glaube unterwäsche von aliexpress ist wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
als von kick von dem was da drinne ist an schadstoffen
aber die hat aber auch beine irgendwie wie ich wie mein arm
gut wie dem auch sei wir wollen wir wollen uns gar keine grill fashion angucken oder
so auf aliexpress das hat jetzt eigentlich gar nicht vor ihr wollt ein bisschen einkaufen
und zwar meine meine ultraschall sensoren sind immer noch nicht angekommen
ich glaube langsam die kommen nicht mehr an und zwar ihr wisst euch hatte als ultraschall
sensor hat ich den hier den da problem ist der ist fünf volt und fünf
volt funktioniert mit meinem esp 32 nicht deswegen wollte ich mit den nachfolger bestellen
nämlich den da der heißt einfach p oder plus das ist das ist tatsächlich eigentlich
aber es funktioniert nicht weil die dinger sind nicht lieferbar in deutschland ja oder
halt hier aus china deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich bestelle das irgendwie in england
oder so irgendwie fortronix oder wie dieser komische laden das da da habe ich bestellt
und irgendwie kommt es nicht an schon seit über einer woche bestellt in england dass
es schneller da ist aber in der zeit hätte ich auch bei er auch in china bestellen können
skar maas ja huge skar maas was ich mache ich kaufe elektronik zeug in schila ein und
danach programmieren ein bisschen
dem mac g fragt ich sehe gerade was findet die sachen auf dem desktop taugen die was
ja für bild bearbeitung snoops wie mich ist das ding wirklich nice ok ich müsste mal
updaten das ist schon nicht die neueste version mehr das ist das ist sehr günstig im vergleich
zu photoshop und sowas oder in der in der richtung und es kann eigentlich jeder der
sich ein bisschen mit dem programm beschäftigt ordentliche samtnails damit machen was wird
programmiert ich wollte mal ein bisschen multithreading testen auf mehr sp 32 und das zeug
ist auch gar nicht so teuer die haben die haben zwei sachen die haben hier einmal den
affinity designer und die haben einmal also die publisher das ist für leute die irgendwelche
layouts machen wollen habe ich ausbilden die haben quasi die pixel foto bearbeitung und
so ein bisschen so ein bisschen zwischen den zwischen bild bearbeitung und layout kram
der designer man kann mit dem design aber auch pixel sachen bearbeiten und man kann
auch mit dem mit dem foto ein bisschen ein bisschen also das nimmt sich nicht so viel
ist ein bisschen unterschiedlicher schwerpunkt aber die dingen sind gut und das schöne ist
der kram ist gar nicht so teuer was kosten der aktuelle designer ich meine guck mal leute
da kann es nichts sagen 43 euro ich glaube dass das nicht ich glaube nicht also ja das
ist eine lifetime lizenz allerdings sind die updates glaube ich nur für die jeweilige
version mit drinne irgendwie so aber bei dem preis kannst du dich nicht beschweren alles
andere was fotomäßig ist und was kann ist übertrieben schweine teuer und ich finde
auch die bedienung nicht gut dabei bei diesem affinity zeug finde ich die bedienung eigentlich
ganz nice da können auch wirklich foto bild bearbeitung snoops wie ich ordentliche ordentliche
samtnil zwar ich meine wenn man bei mir guckt wenn man bei mir guckt auf youtube da sind
mit sich aber geh weg bei mir auf youtube guckt ich meine da sind mit sicherheit nicht
die schönsten samtnils die ich hier produziert habe ja die sind die sind aber zumindest
ein ticken über über über paint ja und sowas kann man sowas kann man damit ganz gut machen
man kann damit natürlich noch viel viel mehr machen keine frage aber ich ich ich tu mir
ja schon ich tu mir ja schon schwer samtnils zu erzeugen mit irgendwas und mittlerweile
ich krieg's eigentlich mittlerweile ganz gut hin da habe ich ja das das blödes in get
freien bild einfach gefunden warum habe ich eigentlich so viele twitch emotes in meinen
in meinen videos auf youtube
ja wie dem auch sei ich finde die dinger taugen was und die sachen sind wirklich günstig
für das was sie können kann man kann man auch kann man echt empfehlen den kram wie
ist das im vergleich zu gimp keine ahnung ich habe gimp noch nie benutzt mich hat die
oberfläche immer übelst abgeschreckt
ich finde das gut ich habe das absichtlich gemacht dass die neueste nachricht oben ist
so dann machen wir weiter mit unserem china zeug affinity für linux ja das wäre schön
aber ich glaube das werden wir nicht sehen weil die auch teilweise 3d also grafika an
beschleunigung so verwenden wobei gerade die sollten eigentlich unter ledigungsgut funktionieren
also immer das wird das wäre aber schön
was 4059 inch wo steht das
nein das ist eher was anderes
sebaro das ist dass du dir den neuen raspberry pi 4 holst dass du endlich deine 24k bildschirme
in meiner suchleiste stimmt 4049 inch tv
was auch immer das ist gibt es gar nicht okay gut job aliexpress
es wird ja immer es wird ja immer abgedrehter was uns hier empfohlen wird jetzt ist ja gar
nichts mehr dran die eben hatte ja zumindest noch halbwegs an allen stellen noch stoff
aber hier gar nichts mehr
also aliexpress ist glaube ich echter meinung wir wollen als erstes mal wollen wir heimwerker
tools kaufen garten tools 3d drucker und grill unterwäsche
also eine sache haben wir es gestern schon gefunden und zwar
hier haben wir es drin gespeichert
ok also muss ich aliexpress noch mal hier noch mal hier auf machen
falsche falscher broser
banggood
so ja ja ihr freut euch alle so sehr dass ich wieder da bin china seiten ist klar
genau weil könnte man schiener schiener zeug speichern dass wir haben es tatsächlich
gestern in drei stunden geschafft kabel zu kaufen das ist eigentlich der witz schlechthin
gut also dann ich muss mal meine einkaufsliste aufmachen
food bei aliexpress ok moment da wollte ich jetzt mal wirklich danach gucken food
das sind das sind behälter eulen behälter das das das das ich finde allein das sieht
übelst aus
fisch food pils ok was alle das ist eine seite kannst du ewig drauf rum gucken ewig
ja
ok also wir machen also was brauchen wir noch kabel haben wir gefunden als nächstes brauche
ich noch
ach stimmt ich wollte mal ich wollte mal gucken was mein ob es mit meinen staubsauger robotter
günstig gibt noch einen zweiten
weil das gibt es jetzt mittlerweile nachfolger modell dass man nicht mehr flaschen kann ich
habe gehofft vielleicht gibt es das alte modell jetzt relativ günstig
oh man darf sogar chip from germany wieder auswählen
ist das ja nice
viel zu teuer
viel zu teuer ey
da muss da muss ich auf ein angebot waren ist viel zu teuer gerade hier stellen wollen
wir stellen mal auf euro um
euro viel zu teuer
ich würde ich würde nie 330 euro den schimmer kaufen
ich habe ich habe eins auf alternate gekauft
ja das haben wir gestern schon angeguckt gestern sind wir dann drauf gekommen es gibt ppega
t-shirts bei alle ernsthaft da muss man gleich danach suchen
da sind wir dann drauf gekommen dass ich euch doch mal das web interface von einem staubsauger
zeigen könnte gestern das haben wir gestern schon gemacht stimmt ppega
krass
warum gibt es mal aliexpress ppega t-shirts warum gibt es ppega rucksäcke
gibt es monka s
du scheiße
warum hat aliexpress t-shirts
kriegst du wahrscheinlich auch ausschlag wenn du das anziehst
vor allem für babies
warum braucht man den baby strampel anzug mit monka s drauf
jebaited
nee ich glaube das gibt es nicht
weil das weil das geschützt ist von twitch
wobei als wird es als wird es die chinesen interessieren ja
ok anscheinend doch
twitch emote
tatsächlich die chinesen alter was die alles haben
die interessiert das allerdings wahrscheinlich mal absolut gar nicht dass manche sachen auch
von twitch geschützt sind oder so
das juckt die einfach nicht
die machen das einfach
ja jebaited strampler monka s strampler
das das braucht man
genial
ja
pepehands
nein gibt es nicht
na gut was ist denn das
ok wir machen mal nicht ships from germany
was ist denn der günstigste sortier nach price
was
ok was ist denn der günstigste
das ist der falsche das ist auch der falsche s 50 habe ich gesucht
ok der günstigste sind 315 euro oder sagt man mal hier irgendwie ein shop der schon
was gekauft hat
328 euro das ist ganz schön teuer ich weiß nicht ob ich mir für den preis noch einen
zweiten kaufen will
ich meine das ding ist wirklich sehr nice eu plug type
versandt aus check republic
polen
franz
spain
oder aus russland
weiß mein das auch in weiß
43 euro das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht ich hab in deutschland bei einer aktion bei alternate
habe ich noch weniger bezahlt
warum warum soll ich warum soll ich
was mein deals.de da gucken wir uns gleich mal nach
warum warum soll ich denn
warum sollte ich das überhaupt auf aliexpress kaufen
ja da kommen wir jetzt in preisregion her und das wird kommt wahrscheinlich auch aus
leider wird es erst unter 300 hot sehe ich auch so
was zum teusch ist die labs für eine seite kann ich das jetzt aufmachen
igitt aspirateur connect
der aspirateur den brauche ich
franzosen shop
gut also aktuell zu teuer lohnt sich nicht den zweiten zu kaufen
wie gesagt haben ein für irgendwie 250 oder irgendwie 260 in der aktion bei alternate
gekriegt
das lohnt sich so aktuell nicht
jetzt trage ich den lieber vom erdgeschoss den ersten stock hoch
wie lange dauert der stream schon 20 minuten
ok also staubsauger robotter ist abgehakt machen wir nicht
support kabel habe ich gekauft passt
dann wollte ich mal gucken ob die noch ein paar miflora sensoren haben
das ist ein
kann man in garten beziehungsweise im hof oder auf die terrasse oder auf irgendwelche pflanzen
im haus oder kann man das rein stöpseln
und das kann man ein paar plutus abfragen
was die pflanze für eine bodenfeuchtigkeit hat nährstoffe im boden lichteinstrahlung
und temperatur
das ist sehr praktisch dass man weiß von wieder gießen gehen muss
ist im prinzip ein bisschen so das was wir mal selbst gebaut haben
von ein paar streams
also was er selbst gebaut mit dem Arduino und dem sensor dran
bloß dass es schon fix und fertig ist mit plutus
die balte batterien halten auch relativ lang und es ist so eine 0815
weiß nicht was für eine batterie wie das heißt so ganz normale kleine runde batterie
die muss man nein die flasht man nicht
weil die kann man zwar mit der offiziellen app verwenden
man kann sie aber auch direkt über plutus abfragen gibt's auf github
für alle möglichen plattformen
gibt's für gibt's auf github libraries die die dinge über plutus abfragen können
das ist wirklich
das abzufragen
so und dann müssen wir mal gucken wo es halbwegs günstig ist
die letzten habe ich auf banggood gekauft
der seitenname ist immer noch ganz ganz kranios
und die waren
richtig
huge günstig
aber jetzt nimmt sich nicht viel 13 euro
zu 12 euro
hier ist auch versandt aus china
das lohnt sich dann nicht
wat banggood wie siehts bei gearbest aus
haben sie gar nicht ok
ship from germany oh gibt's welche hier
debated
kannst du erst mal danach suchen kannst du einstellen ships germany
und dann denied
äh übrigens die kamera hier ist ganz gut
die kann man wiederum flaschen
die kann man flaschen
die wird bei amazon kommen
wird die unter weiß camp an verkauft
und ist übertrieben
beliebt
das ist die gleiche ist jetzt noch
kein unterschied das ist das ist
dieses schallumi
dings kameradings
nur mit dem unterschied
dass die hier 11 euro kostet
und hier halt 34 dollar
die kamera ist insofern ganz gut
am weil man flaschen kann
und relativ easy
relativ easy flaschen kann
also die ist jetzt das ist jetzt gewinnt sie keinen qualitätspreis mit der
kamera
aber die ist günstig
kosten wenn ich aus germany bestelle
die SD karte kostet
jebaited
ich verstehe immer noch nicht wieso sich schallumi hinter x 1000 marken haben
versteckt
weil soweit ich weiß
ist schallumi macht die dinger gar nicht selbst
die haben so das ist so ein bisschen so eine
so eine werfe gibt es gibt es in deutschland auch so was
so ein so ein so ein überding für unterschiedliche marken
die typen
die diesen pflanzensensor bauen sind nicht die typen die die handys bauen
und so
das ist quasi so eine firma mit ganz vielen unterdivisions irgendwie
schallumi
wie spricht man das eigentlich auf chinesisch aus
allumi
schallumi
ja schallumi klingt
also oft oft oft oft oft japanisch wird es wahrscheinlich heißen schallumi
die sind bald die sind bald immer da sehr zackig bei der aussprache
schallumi
also zumindest die kamera lohnt sich
wenn man die selbst flasht
davon wollte ich ein paar kaufen hier kostet das zwölf euro das stück
was hast du mit dem esp32 vor
ich wollte also wir haben in den letzten paar streams haben wir schon ein bisschen
esp32 programmiert
ich wollte mir heute mal das multiscreading angucken
letztendlich ist das alles immer noch für den
diesmal ist es
für den sensor an der tür
an am hoftor der gucken soll man es oft auf und zu geht
und ob post im briefkasten ist
aber ich will erst mal ein bisschen multiscreading testen
einfach was man damit machen kann ich mein das ding hat zwei cpu cores
und ähm
den low power core
einfach mal gucken einfach mal gucken was funktioniert
in dem fall will ich brauche ich für also nicht direkt für den für den
esp32 der am hoftor ist
sondern für den der die ganze sache dann quasi von dem relate bei mir ins
wlan
an mein mqtt server
da wollte ich mal probieren ob man nicht einfach das so machen kann
dass man quasi die ganze
traffic geschichte was ähm
netzwerk angeht auf dem einen core laufen lässt
und ähm
das ganze mqtt gesende und keep alive zeug auf dem anderen
mqtt ja genau
das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
ich hab
noch nicht multiscreading damit ausprobiert
deswegen wollte ich mir das einfach mal angucken was da wie wie man das so
macht
ja aber erst mal muss ich china einkaufen
ok am
also zwölf euro
für ein stück
finde ich eigentlich ganz ok ehrlich gesagt
es ist so für die bluetooth sache übrigens vollkommen egal
ob das die chinesische version ist oder die internationale version
geht alles per bluetooth auszulesen
es wäre ein unterschied welche app man verwendet
der pi 4 ist immer noch ausverkauft ja übelst schwierig zu kriegen
ich hab jetzt ich hab ja einen
ich hab ja einen bestellt haben wir uns ja auch hier im stream angeguckt
sache ist plus die erstens habe ich keinen verwendungszweck gerade für
und zweitens
so im nachhinein nachdem wir jetzt den stream gemacht haben und sich das ein paar tage
gesetzt hat
bin ich nicht so richtig begeistert davon
das sind die einzigen zwei riesen plus die der raspberry pi 4 hat aus meiner
sicht
ist usb 3 und ordentlich angebunden gigabit ethernet
das ist schon was ist auf jeden fall lange überfällig
aber der rest haut mich jetzt nicht vom hocker
und was mich enttäuscht hat ist
dass die irgendwie keine krypto extensions in der cpu drinne haben
vielleicht gehen die aber auch nur unter für den 64 bit betriebssystem vielleicht
liegt auch daran
oder sie haben es einfach weggelassen
ok also 12 euro ist ok gibt es da vielleicht welche
warehouse deutschland habe ich schon ausprobiert
ja dann
da könnte man ein paar von bestellen noch
noch mal fünf stück
am wird mich dann kosten
ok kann man dann eh packen ich finde es so heftig man kann für 95 cent aus
china sich was bestellen mit tracking nummer
die is soll in der 64 bit gehen ich hoffe
das wäre übertrieben geil
weil dann kann man das auch so als als sehr günstiges nass sehr günstige
netzwerksspeicher verwenden
der für viele leute ausreicht
ja aktuell ist es ein bisschen lahm
also mit verschlüsselung was sie wieder 30 mb 25 mb die sekunde
sagt
funktioniert also davon könnte ich mir mal ein paar bestellen
oder ich warte bis es noch ein bisschen billiger ist weil ich ich bilde mir ein
die letzten habe ich für acht euro das stück gekriegt bei banggood
also holen holen wir noch nicht
ich habe noch drei übrig aber braucht man immer wieder
dann wollte ich mal gucken ob es wieder
sie wave dort sensors gibt
kann man nämlich nie genug haben
ich hätte nämlich auch noch gerne für die keller fenster welche
aber ich sehe schon die sind aktuell
gerade ein bisschen teuer
ja die sind aktuell kann ein bisschen teuer
das lohnt sich gerade nicht so richtig
das lohnt sich gerade nicht so wirklich das ist ein bisschen teuer
also das günstigste was es gibt ist 11 euro das stück ich meine das ist immer
noch billiger als auf amazon.de wo sowas irgendwie 30 euro kostet
aber da kann ich noch mal warten ein bisschen vielleicht haben die zu weihnachten wieder
irgendeine special aktion wo es die günstiger gibt also ich habe ja bei mir überall im haus
verteilt
heute bei shopping ja
ich habe überall überall bei mir im haus verteilt also mein ziel ist dass ich an jedem
an jedem außenfenster ein hab und an den wichtigsten türen dass man weiß wann die
sachen geöffnet und geschlossen werden so dass man eben weiß wenn man zum beispiel
vergisst ein fenster zuzumachen ich habe sie mich schon hingekriegt dass ich im keller
gelüftet habe und dann bin ich weg und habe vergessen das kellerfenster zuzumachen das
kann dir dann nicht passieren
ja wenn ich auf alibaba den hersteller anschreibe dann muss ich wahrscheinlich gleich mal 50
stück nehmen oder so das ist mir dann ein bisschen viel oder hast du damit erfahrung
ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert
also das kann ich auch abhaken das lohnt sich jetzt gerade nicht
dann bräuchte ich unbedingt mal wieder eine ganze ladung einmal micro usb kabel
ich hätte gerne so ein 50er pack am liebsten
dann werde ich endlich mal ruhe ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wo ich irgendwie habe
ich ich kauf mir immer usb kabel und irgendwie werden die immer weniger und ich weiß nicht
wo die hingehen kennt ihr das problem ich sag ok brauchen wir mal hier zum anschließen
von dem controller usb micro usb zack angeschlossen nächstes mal wieder ich brauche wieder ein
usb kabel und irgendwie ist es weg
denn die katz frisst sie bestimmt nicht
haben die hier so einen schönen 50er pack oder sowas micro usb kabel das wäre mal nice
aber was ist denn mit dem los das sieht ein bisschen unförmig aus
ginge ist mir fast egal hauptsache viel usb kabel
50 ja 50 ja ein meter ist schon nicht verkehrt
moment das aber kein 50 das ist doch mal eine hausnummer
was kosten auf amazon so usb kabel wahrscheinlich 5 euro oder sowas
ok das hier sind ein dreier pack ein dreier pack also ok na gut kommen auf amazon bezahlt
man 250 ungefähr für einen dreier pack
was sogar mit usb adapter ernsthaft
wo hast du das gesehen bei denen hier oder bei dem anderen sebaro wo hast du das gesehen
achso
im bild ja ich dachte auch dass es ein usb c ist aber ich glaube das ist einfach nur
doof
ach moment
kann man das groß machen kann man das entlatschen
das sieht tatsächlich aus wie ein usb c
könnte aber auch ein lightning sein aber hier sieht es aus wie ein usb c
ist da irgendwo
die schreiben sowas doch dabei wenn es das hat
das ist nur usb c oder ja geil nice
ich glaube das bestelle ich mir also das klingt das klingt doch echt das klingt doch echt
nice
50er pack ein meter kabel sowohl micro usb als auf usb 2
ist iphone x nicht mittlerweile usb c
oder ist das noch lightning
iphone x ist lightning
aber es sieht halt einfach nicht aus wie lightning
ach wer weiß was die chinesen da schreiben
das hier sieht aus wie lightning das hier sieht wieder nicht aus wie lightning
ist lightning
und lightning ist dumm das sieht aber nicht aus wie lightning
lightning hat lightning hat auf beiden seiten pins
und das hat nicht auf beiden seiten pins
ja genau ich gucke einfach ob der hersteller noch mehr hat
irgendwo sieht man hier nochmal den hersteller die seite verwirrt mich manchmal echt
unten stehen immer die sachen die der hersteller noch so hat
type-c hier und warum ist es jetzt auf einmal so teuer
das sind das sind das sind jetzt wie viel stück
ach das sind das sind so super high speed charge dinger
all die musik
was in der überschrift von den bildern steht usb c du meinst hier
ich habe gerade nach usb c gesucht auf der seite
habe ich nix gefunden
das war ein 100 stück aber was ich mega nice finden würde
ganz ehrlich was ich mega nice finden würde wenn es wenn es das hier wirklich gebe
micro usb mit mit usb c adapter das wäre ultra nice weil es ist genau das was man
braucht aktuell braucht man zum größten teil
micro usb und in zukunft brauchst du wahrscheinlich
vermehrt usb c und da könnte ich mir einmal einen 50er pack kaufen
heute wird wirklich ein schiener gekauft ja 50 usb kabel haben
dass ich meinen ganzen krempel anschließen kann ich habe immer zu wenig usb kabel immer
und letztendlich braucht jeder controller jeder raspberry jeder
jeder furz braucht heute ein usb kabel und wenn ich mir jetzt einfach mal einen
ordentlichen 50er pack kaufe
und die hätten sogar micro usb und usb c wäre mega nice
dann hätte ich jetzt einfach mal auf jahre ausgesorgt was usb kabel angeht
die muss ich mir nochmal genau anfangen die werde ich mir wahrscheinlich bestellen
zumal es auch ziemlich günstig ist ich meine mit dhl auch noch ok
free shipping mit dhl
hier die muss ich eigentlich bestellen
klar reichen die ohne raspberry zu betreiben
da kommt es ja weniger auf das usb kabel mehr auf das netzteil an
die werde ich bestellen
also das hier ist definitiv ein usb c und kein lightning adapter
ich muss mir mal angucken wie so ein charger aussieht
iphone x charger iphone x cable
das ist 0815 lightning shit
ok ich glaube die chinesen wissen nicht so genau was sie schreiben
50 usb kabel guck mal was es noch gibt
aber das ist übertrieben günstig
das ist quasi ein usb kabel mit micro usb und usb c für ein euro das stück
das ist schon echt günstig
das bestelle ich hatten die nicht so ein chat oder war das
das war alibaba mit dem chat
war glaube ich alibaba mit dem chat wo man den hersteller fragen kann
contact
ah nee muss ich mich einloggen
das war ich frage die mal ob das ob das wirklich lightning ist oder usb c wenn das usb c ist
wird es ins instant gebeilt
pc lustig doch theoretisch schon aber eigentlich egal also usb c auf micro usb wäre aus dem
sind besser weil ich irgendwo in einem video mal gesehen habe dass die usb c stecker weniger
heiß werden und weniger widerstand haben und deswegen irgendwie die besseren stecker
sind
aber letztendlich
ich meine bei der kabellänge von irgendwie 25 cm
was meint ihr was soll ich kaufen soll ich den soll ich den meter bestellen oder lieber
also ganz ehrlich leute mir juckt es in den fingern in meter und 25 cm zu bestellen allerdings
ist es total bescheuert
ich brauche nie im leben die nächsten jahre 100 usb kabel
sim karten pins verlier ich nie
ein meter ja denke ich auch ich meine die parcenti ist da mehr kostet
die parcenti ist mehr kostet ich bestelle den meter ich bestelle den meter usb kabel
was hast du dir letztens gekauft ok
was das zeigt mal her
ach so ein multidink so ein hybrid ding ja
ja die sind auch ganz praktisch
was auch gut ist wo ich auch mal gucken wollte noch was mir aufgeschrieben hat ich hätte
gerne usb magnetic ein paar allerdings nicht für microcontroller
oder raspberries oder so sondern wirklich um tablets und geräte aufzuladen
weil die sind auch echt praktisch
da machst du in jedes gerät machst du so einen so einen so einen ippel rein da vorne
und das kabel kannst du einfach nur anklicken
oh huge donation was gab's warte ich muss mal in der vorschau gucken
danke schon mal für die donation ich muss erstmal warten bis das angezeigt wird
ich hab nur den sound gehört
ok oder wird nicht angezeigt dann muss ich mal kurz in tippe stream gucken was das gewesen
ist
und zwar schreibt er max ich hab mir vorgenommen nicht jeden tag mit der partnerbewerbung zu
nerven so dass du es dass du sonst wieder vergisst nerven nerven nerven lol da steht
null zeichen übrig ja die haben zwar wahrscheinlich auch nicht gecheckt mal zu überprüfen wie
lang der input ist aber insofern wahrscheinlich wenn du mich jeden tag mit einer euro donation
nervst ist es wahrscheinlich für mich im endeffekt lukrativer nicht partner zu werden
huge brain quickmaps so siehts aus ja
ok nochmal schnell gucken was hat denn der andere was hat denn der hersteller hier noch
für dinger gehabt der hatte der hatte die dinger das war aber reines usb c ne usb c
reines usb c will ich nicht also diese diese hybridgeschichte aus micro usb und so das
reizt mich jetzt echt zu kaufen das kann ich halt gebrauchen haben die ernsthaft hundert
in ihr kopfhörer bestimmt massiv soundqualität klinkeanschluss da haben die iphone besitzer
schon mal verloren erst mal 100 in ihr bestellen wie viel holt jetzt wird es aber teuer 100
centimeter das sind aus bc ich tipp immer noch drauf dass das wirklich usb c und micro
usb äh dass das hier wirklich micro usb und usb c ist und die chinesen einfach nur die
überschrift falsch geschrieben haben iphone iphone ich glaube die haben es einfach noch
falsch geschrieben übrigens habe ich euch mal erzählt wie easy das ist bei aliexpress
geld zurück zu kriegen das hätte ich nie gedacht das geht schneller als bei amazon
oder ip oder oder oder paypal ich habe was habe ich bestellt bei aliexpress wurscht geld
zurück was ich weiß ich glaube in den sensor kram war das denn was habe ich da bestellt
ich kann mir jetzt nicht daran erinnern zumindest haben die mir eine sendeverfolgungsnummer
geschickt ich habe eine woche gewartet ging nicht ging nicht ging nicht habe ich die angeschrieben
dass jungs irgendwie stimmt die sendeverfolgungsnummer nicht kannst bei aliexpress kannst du einfach
so einen fall aufmachen also bisschen wie bei paypal käufer schutz amazon pay käufer schutz
und da haben die darauf geantwortet haben gesagt wir haben uns vertan hier haben sie
eine neue hier haben sie eine neue trackingnummer aber das war chinas gamas sie haben mir einfach
die gleiche trackingnummer noch mal geschickt und die ging natürlich immer noch nicht
und habe ich zurückgeschrieben leute falsche trackingnummer und dann hat aliexpress dann
hat aliexpress sich eingeschaltet also dieses käufer schutzprogramm aliexpress und haben
wohl dem hersteller gesagt hier teilt ihr das jetzt mal mit und haben zu mir gesagt
ich soll innerhalb von zwei tagen in das ticket reinschreiben ob jetzt ob ich jetzt zufrieden
bin ob alles passt genau ich habe sogar ursprünglich nur aufgemacht weil die den fall als ist angekommen
markiert haben obwohl überhaupt noch nichts losgeschickt wurde und ich habe mich nicht
gemeldet in zwei tagen und es ist nicht so wie du das teilweise bei anderen sachen gewöhnt
bist dass wenn du dich zwei tage nicht meldest dass dann der fall geschlossen wird und gesagt
wird ah der händler hat recht nee nee ich habe mich zwei tage nicht gemeldet und auf
einmal mein geld wieder gekriegt also das ist auf aliexpress viel besser als man denkt
ja easy geld zurück aus china also bis jetzt überhaupt kein problem einmal kam auch was
kaputten ist an da habe ich hier so ein board bestellt so was hier habe ich so ein board
bestellt oder zwei boards so was ähnliches wie wie das hier das da das da habe ich das
genau das habe ich bestellt allerdings glaube ich in die version 3 kam mit kaputtem display
an sein jungs display kaputt haben sie gesagt schicken wir noch mal das hat sich überhaupt
nicht gejuckt also ich muss sagen ich bin wirklich sehr zufrieden bisher immer mit aliexpress
einkäufen gewesen naja gut genug usb kabel geguckt die habe ich mir mal gespeichert ja
sie baro die haben auf aliexpress kriegst du wirklich adapter für alles 100 kabel ich
will keine 100 kabel ich will nur 50 kabel außerdem sind es 100 sind das 50 einmeter
kabel das überhaupt kein ding die kommen hier ins schrank und gut ist streamst du jetzt
regelmäßig also wenn man sich so die letzten paar wochen anguckt scheine ich tatsächlich
wieder erwartend regelmäßig zu streamen was mich selbst überrascht wurde schon mal die
neue firmware für den pie 4 angesprochen nee habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert allerdings
kann ich das bestätigen auch bei mir im stream wobei nee du beziehst dich auf den stream
bei mir also ja auch bei mir war der raspberry pie extrem heiß und das schon mit passiv
kühler drauf ja ich gucke mal bei alibaba aber ich also ganz ehrlich 50 50 euro für
50 usb kabel kann ich mit leben okay haben wir auch geguckt usb kabel werden wir auch
bestellen dann wollte ich mal gucken ob die wieder billige micro sd karten haben micro
sd karten bei aliexpress ist so ein zweischneidiges schwert weil micro sd karten willst ja eigentlich
in der regel dass die dinger zuverlässig sind und die verkaufen hier jede menge angebliche
samsung micro sd wo man sich echt fragen muss ob die dinger wirklich von samsung sind aber
manchmal haben die wirklich ziemlich günstige sachen im stadt am start informatiker kriegen
zu viel geld man kriegt prinzipiell eigentlich nicht so nie zu viel geld was kostet ein akt
was kosten so ein 10er pack micro sd karten bei von dem hersteller schon nie was gehört
was kostet eine micro micro sd karte aktuell mit 32 g 32 4 euro 799 okay was ist das für
eine klasse kenne ich nicht 10 sagt ist das richtig schreudig am besten ist man holt a1
a1 a1 ist gut micro usb a1 warum kostet die 63 cent die micro sd karte der adapter von
micro sd auf sd kostet 63 cent ja genau darauf habe ich gewartet dass ich mir das kaufen
darf das ist aber das ist echt nicht schlechter preis die frage ist halt ob es original karte
ist oder ob es fake ist guck mal sieben euro bei amazon 282 gerade 69 prozent reduziert
bei aliexpress mir geht es nicht um die mir geht es nicht um die mb pro sekunde es geht
darum wie viele insgesamt aushalten unterhalten die a1 deutlich mehr aus als die
als die klasse 10 die also man muss ja überhaupt sagen diese diese klassen kategorisierung
für sd karten ist eines der undurchsichtigsten schemas die es so gibt ich habe mir gemerkt
a1 ist gut alles andere sackt runter habe ich mir irgendwann mal gemerkt ich kann es nicht
mehr begründen aber ich ich habe mir das wahrscheinlich nicht einfach so ohne grund
gemerkt klasse 10 ist so dass nur noch 15 dingen was auch in dem respekt relativ schnell mal
kaputt geht a1 ist ok moment ist klasse 10 das gleiche wie a1 vielleicht erzähle ich
euch jetzt auch kann mist gucken wir mal bla bla bla bla bla bla bla ja hier ist eine schöne
beschreibung also das ist übelst wir ne es geht bei dieser ganzen geschichte auch soweit
ich weiß ein bisschen um die wie robust der ganze kram sind und a1 ist quasi für application
geschichten ausgelegt also zum beispiel sowas wie vielleicht erzähle ich euch jetzt auch
übelst bullshit aber so habe ich mir das mal gemerkt muss aber gucken jetzt ob das stimmt
dass a1 für application geschichten ausgelegt sind und dieses andere zeug halt für sequenziell
ab und zu mal was schreiben also für audio video zeug allerdings finde ich jetzt überhaupt
nicht mehr das ist ein sehr das ist ein ultra verwirrendes schema
ist übelst wir 60 vor 90 also dass das das schema von micro sd karten ich werde es wahrscheinlich
nie checken wenn eins ok dann ist eins und zehn vielleicht echt das gleiche was mich
wundert ich habe mir irgendwann mal gemerkt a1 ist gut für application geschichten aber
vielleicht ist es einfach auch bullshit da muss ich auch zugeben können wenn man scheiße
erzählt ja ok a1 und 10 ist das gleiche dann habe ich es bestellt da können wir uns den
kram aber auf jeden fall bestellen und das lohnt sich also wenn das kein fake ist wenn
das fake ist ist natürlich skmars angesagt allerdings man könnte es mal drauf ankommen
lassen bei amazon kostet sieben euro bei aliexpress kostet 282 das heißt da könnte man schon
mal so einen 20er pack bestellen
geliefert bevor 22 ja gut das ist ja noch eine halbe monate hin ach das hat kein tracking
ich bin verwirrt warum gibt es bei einer ok ganz ohne tracking ist ist ist mist
also ja dann am ehest noch aliexpress standard shipping aber die lieferzeiten sind halt wieder
krass was heißt das hier überhaupt amen nehmen lieber andere aber die sind schon billig
da wirst du aber micro sd karten kannst du einfach skmars werden aber micro sd karten
ist noch was was ich mir kaufen würde bei aliexpress batterien und und akkus würde
ich mir auf keinen fall holen weil micro sd karten gehen im zweifelsfall nicht oder gehen
im zweifelsfall kaputt aber bei akkus hast du probleme weil die können dir halt auch
mal abfackeln also aliexpress akkus trau ich nicht das mocha smoke ist dann angesagt es
gibt genug berichte im hinterhalt von leuten die sich akkus und und batterien aliexpress
bestellt haben und die es glücklicherweise in der garage oder so gelagert haben und das
ding ist entweder geplatzt abgefackelt oder sonst was also würde ich nicht machen das
denn lexar habe ich ja noch nie gehört als anbieter 137 das ist noch günstiger als die
fake sandisk lexar sehr gut ich werde mir die mal speichern vielleicht hole ich mir da
auch noch ein 10er pack mal gucken ist jedenfalls relativ günstig greift die hausradversicherung
baschine akkus ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
was mit mix hast du probiert von habe ich ja noch nie gehört dann halt drauf v10 10 1
das ist alles die klar kann das sein dass klar 10 a1 und v10 die exakt das gleiche
ist was du hast 400 micro sd karten für 12 euro gekauft und das kam an oder ist denen
aufgefallen dass sie irgendwie müsste eingestellt haben mix habe ich noch nie gehört aber auch
mal eine überlegung wert also bunt sind sie auf jeden fall schon mal ich meine ich habe
schon gedacht als mir amazon mal aus versehen den 20er pack micro sd karten geschickt hat
ich habe jetzt für immer genug pro karte 12 euro das ist das ist ja zu teuer also je
nachdem was es für eine micro sd karte ist wie groß sind die karten die du gekauft hast
ok das haben wir auch bestellt das war es zum größten teil was ich in china kaufen
wollte aber fast alles gefunden ich wollte mir noch ein paar magnete holen wobei die
holt man lieber bei amazon was für irgendwelche die so 2 kilo halten können oder sowas allerdings
hier in der richtung aber da muss man gucken dass jetzt nicht so akut jetzt ab zum inder
ja der inder ist hier oder war oder war bengot bengot war indisch oder bengt auch china gucken
wir mal im pressum wo ha ha ha ha jebaited im pressum gibt es nicht braucht man ja auch
nicht und so die brauchen das wirklich nicht in china oder indien nirgt das kein mensch
kann man auch mal so ein azika kaufen für plega 5 was in echt wahrscheinlich nur halb
so gut ausschauen funktioniert wie auf dem bild ok na ist ja wir haben ja alles alles
gekriegt bei amazon bei amazon alles gekriegt jetzt für fast bei aliexpress was wir brauchen
also wo ich mich wirklich drauf freue wenn es das wenn das ich muss die mal fragen ob
das hier mikro ob das hier wirklich usb c ist oder ob das bild einfach nur fail ist dann
kaufe ich mir die in den 50er pack micro sd micro sd usb c kabel das ist genau das was
ich brauche huge da habe ich massiv viele usb kabel dann könnt ihr noch ein bisschen
mehr details hier reinschreiben ne white blue rose red orange ich nehme das zebra usb
kabel akzeptieren sehr schön ach hier haben sie auch noch mehr ach jawoll 1400 usb kabel
jetzt geht es ab ist nicht länger available ich hätte mir gerne 1400 usb kabel gekauft
max hast du gerade wirklich micro sd micro usb karten gesagt ich falls ich das gesagt
habe will ich jetzt mal nicht ausschließen man ist das ist zu viel zeugs zu viel aliexpress
hast du einen hubverhang für den usb lager ja wenn ich 1400 karten brauche wenn ich
1400 usb kabel kaufe da brauche ich mal zumindest so ein sackkarre und warum brauche ich 100
100 klinke stecker was auch immer wir haben eingekauft alles gut nice gg gl hf alles
soll mal fragen schnell gucken was haben wir denn haben wir irgendwas vergessen drei entwürfe
für monka smog ja das sobald wir emotes haben nehmen wir deinen monka smog als erstes
emote ach ja wir müssen noch abstimmen welcher monka smog am besten ist ich persönlich tendiere
ja irgendwie zum dritten monka smog weil der dritte monka smog halt smog hat das ist eher
monka burn und das ist das ist das ist monka brain explode keine ahnung monka binderhautentzündung
das ist monka abfackeln und das ist monka smog aber den den vote machen wir dann wenn
ich wenn ich emotes habe vorher hat er keinen sinn aber ich tendiere zu dem weil ich glaube
da sieht auch klein ganz cool aus zu null mal gucken wie das wieder wie das bild wie das
klein aussieht warum kann man das nicht kleiner machen alter windows da fack ich will es einfach
nur kleiner machen ok da muss ich sie doch in was passiert wenn man auf erde drückt
aber aber den smog noch so gut erkennt
ungefähr so groß ist das dann das im bau sieht gut aus das hat was oder da kann ich
mir so richtig vorstellen dass dem grad irgendwelche china steckdosen abgefackelt sind das gefällt
mir monka smog so wie viel haben wir jetzt 20 uhr 4 ok wir gucken jetzt noch die fragen
und dann programmieren wir ein bisschen frag mich gerade ob sich so richtig lohnt weil
ich muss halt wieder spätestens 22 uhr ins bett und eigentlich muss ich 21 uhr schon
wieder auf weil ich kann immer nicht pennen wenn ich streben bis 22 uhr und geht an pennen
da kann ich nächste stunde nicht pennen das sagt 3 uhr morgens
das haben wir beantwortet welche bar ich bei i3 verwende pool für abstimmung gibt es
nicht das hatten wir schon hatten wir schon falls du noch ssd brauchst bei saturn gibt
es gerade eine wedi blue ein terabyte für 99 euro ssd habe ich genug
mal die baba kann man machen wie wäre es mit einem ordnungssystem für die kabel in
einem haus dann man könnte rf aldi man könnte auf den auf den bandel den rf aldi pappa machen
und dann bräuchte man quasi im schrank noch ein rf aldi leser wäre dann die advanced
a big brain variante tokyo nice du wirst nicht im chat im stream angezeigt könnte sein das
ist aber nix was ich gesperrt hätte das ist einfach die stream anzeige von von dings
hier von streamlabs
servus wo bloß ich habe mir gestern dein klo video angesehen einfach epic die schüssel
ja das klo video ist schon nice ich meine muss ich überlegen also das klo ist nice
das klo video ist nice und das klo video ist bescheuert das klingt hat fast 100.000 aufrufe
mittlerweile und ich meine in dem video passiert nichts da stehe ich in meinem bad und filme
die klo schüssel aber hat einfach mal 100.000 aufrufe
naja neue firmware müssen uns mal die tage noch anschauen ich habe übrigens was überlegt
was wir machen könnten wir haben jetzt hier so ein fragetool ich habe mir überlegt ob
wir nicht auch noch irgendwas machen für für für themen im stream weil es kommen immer
vorschläge und ich schreibe mir die ein oder anderen sachen auch auf aber ich übersee
was oder vergesst dann irgendwas und es haben ganz viele leute richtig nice vorschläge was
man im stream machen kann
kann man im streamlabs ändern das muss ich mir mal machen dann mach ich das dann weitliste
ich dich dass du auch im streamchat auf auf tauscht
hdmi zu klinke das ist so wie glasfaser zu wasserschlauch
aber sag mal so hdmi zu klinke geht ja irgendwo noch zumindest für den soundanteil könnte
ich mir das vorstellen und bei glasfaser zu wasserschlauch immer noch mein lieblings
adapter ist
wenn du nicht pennen kannst kannst auch gleich weiter streamen das ist mal die logik schlechte
ich hab das ja ich hab das ja schon eine weile vor ich weiß nicht genau wie ich das zumindest
mit meinem heim automatisierungszeug zeigen soll ohne dass ich zu viel privaten sachen
liege
da wollte ich mir die ganze zeit schon mal was überlegen
was ist einstein shop momentan ausrufe zeichen beruf genau der eichler weiß schon bescheid
360 cam aus china genau ganz genau
leute ich fühle mich heute irgendwie
der scheiß läuft ja immer noch
warum läuft er immer noch bonkartos
was das ist das ist eigentlich stand da immer afk kloar mittlerweile stand bonkartos da
eigentlich habe ich habe sie auch in titel geschrieben ich habe gesagt wir wollen ein
bisschen sp 32 multis werden ausprobieren die sache ist die
ich habe nur noch 50 minuten zeit
ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt schon relativ müde
warum spackt der editor so rum
und ich muss dann in 50 minuten auch wirklich off
also ich würde sagen das war mein nächstes stream da haben wir nichts was zu tun
es sei denn er sagt nein max du musst jetzt esp 32 multis werden programmieren
wäre es egal es ist besser wenn ich das nächste mal im stream auch wenn ich ein bisschen ausgeruht
bin zumindest haben heute eine sache geschafft wir haben in china eingekauft indirekt ich
habe zwar nichts bestellt aber ich habe mir die sachen schon gebockt markt
für morgen an gleichen titel ja für morgens für morgen nehme ich dann das china einkaufen
raus
es war klar dass so was jetzt kommt ja ne das war ich nichts damit wenn ich wenn ich
wenn ich ausgeruht bin weil für alle programming geschichten oder programming muss man sich
ein bisschen konzentrieren können ich bin gerade schon zu müde und zu geschafft vom
ganzen dach heute die mal nach an machen kurz
das heißt wir können jetzt noch 50 minuten bisschen so über aktuelle technik dinger
labern gibt es irgendwas was euch gerade besonders beschäftigt oder gibt es auch irgendwas was
wir bei aliexpress kaufen müssen vielleicht
juwelen
dann muss ich jetzt die nächsten 50 minuten das bestript ausführen ok easy
next choice bei aliexpress es gibt so ein paar sachen die suche ich nicht weil wenn
ich die suche dann bonkatoz windows hat irgendwas mit windows 1 angeteasert ok will microsoft
mal wieder lustig sein
ich kündigt windows 1.0 an bei chip ok
eine gute überblende aber es ist nicht nur chip pc welt ich hatte so mal gar ich hatte
mal früher vor irgendwie also wirklich viel früher hatte ich sogar mal den pc welt aber
für ein halbes jahr
pc welt ist dies die seite ist noch schlimmer als chip
aber vor allem ich habe sogar absichtlich abonniert
es gab zeiten da war der max auch mal ein loop und hat tatsächlich pc welt gelesen
irgendwann habe ich dann einfach die ct abonniert und hatte zumindest halbwegs ordentlich artikel
und ich habe die ct bis heute abonniert aber ich lese überhaupt nicht mehr
computer build nee computer build hatte ich nie abonniert
ich habe mir früher ein paar mal computer build am kiosk gekauft und habe festgestellt
schon relativ schnell dass das kompletter bullshit ist
ja flo geht mir auch so ich müsste ja eigentlich mal kündigen weil lesen tue ich sie nicht
ich lese da vielleicht zwei artikel im jahr
die ct hat massiv ich finde dass die
dass die ganze heise geschichte übelst nachgelassen hat
wenn man sich teilweise die news auf heise durchlässt
die schreiben irgendwie dass die it news für für experten oder so sind
wenn man hier sich manchmal artikel durchlässt gut den habe ich jetzt
den habe ich jetzt nicht gelesen aber was die ganz gerne machen ist bei heise artikeln
dass sie dann schreiben hier keine ahnung dns über hatte ich mal bla bla bla bla bla
und wenn du das dann durchliest und denkst dir dann so ok wo ist jetzt eigentlich mal
das technische detail um was es geht steht einfach nicht da
also die heise artikel haben auch nachgelassen und in der ct steht auch relativ wenig drin
was mich noch interessiert
es ist auch schwierig
heise luft genau
übrigens in reddit und subreddit was ich mir immer gerne angucke ist unix porn hat
damit überhaupt nichts zu tun aber nicht dass jetzt gleich hier monka tost kommt
da posten leute ihre ihre frisch gestalten
frisch gestalten desktops
eigentlich ganz interessant zu sehen benutzbar ist davon das wenigste weil ganz ehrlich
wer möchte bitte schön einen desktop haben mit diesen farben
das ist ja das ist ja für die augen schon mal ganz ehrlich lange drauf gucken
aber ich finde es immer ganz interessant zu gucken was die leute so gebastelt haben
das hier sieht zum beispiel ganz brauchbar aus was er da gebastelt hat
außer dass es auch französisch ist das fällt schon mal für mich wieder raus
das gucke ich mir immer ganz gern an da gibt es nur die ein oder andere inspiration
was möchte ich uns damit sagen
ja und ja und matt warum ist dein system auf französisch wenn du es nicht kannst
ist das ist das der big brain move oder oder warum
rap battle gegen manniboy hör mal auf
ich habe mich doch gestern schon über hip hop geschichten ausgelassen
ach so die franzosen stellen ihre ihre sachen gerne auf französisch ein
wohin ging ich ja mit wobei ich ja verfechter bin seine betriebssysteme
und spiele auf englisch zu stellen ich meine ich habe ja auch hier mein
komplettes bedienst dem alles ist auf englisch
das einzige was ich habe ist ich habe deutsch tastatur leaute ich habe indisches
tastatur leaute okay vergesst aber normalerweise will ich dort warum habe
ich indisches tastatur leaute
kann man das löschen keyboard
ok jetzt kommt wieder windows jetzt jetzt kommt wieder jetzt kommt wieder
windows logic ok lasst mal überlegen wo könnte man tastatur layouts löschen
nicht verraten jetzt mal gucken wie jetzt könnt ihr mich mal wieder
bestaunen wie gut ich mit windows zurecht kommen die weißes denkt schon mal gut
keyboard typing
at least keyboard settings
ok hier kann man zumindest schon mal die fault auswählen die fault wollen wir
das aber wie kann ich jetzt das indische die indische tastatur löschen
das indische die indische tastatur löschen edit language und keyboard
options ok leute ich habe keine ahnung wo das geht
add input language da geht der edge auf
du hast nicht auf time und language geklickt ich bin doch in time und
language
ich finde es dass das ist so ein ein wildes zusammen gemischtes ding die
windows 10 settings
jetzt sind wir der alten systemsteuerung
ok leute ich bin nicht in der lage unter der jeweiligen sprache ja das heißt
ich klicke jetzt da irgendwie da drauf oder englisch normales englisch options
kann man nicht riechen kann man die ganze sprache riechen vielleicht auch nicht
muss ich das gleich drunter machen kann ich dann riechen
aha nee
was
wo ist es denn jetzt hier das untere ok das heißt kann ich kann ich jetzt
einfach bemoven dann ist es weg direkt easy
kannst du die sprache auch den selen ohne den windows expert nein kann ich nicht
weil ich keine ahnung von windows habe am nächsten boot blue screen ich würde
es nicht wundern
es war schon wieder aber umständlich als es sein muss so also was haben wir
jetzt noch questions meinung zu golang
ich habe mit go noch nicht viel gemacht wahrscheinlich ist go eine ziemlich
gute sprache das schlussfolge ich da draus dass es viele richtig gute
gitarre projekte gibt in golang und auch für viele bekannte frameworks golang
bindungen also bindings was auf jeden fall dafür deuten darauf deute dass es
benutzt wird ich habe mich nur ganz kleines bisschen mit go beschäftigt und
da hat mir die sonntags nicht so gut gefallen aber das heißt überhaupt nichts
ich wüsste mich damit mal wirklich länger beschäftigen dass ich da was
sinnvolles zu sagen kann wir könnten ja mal wir könnten ja mal
ein stream machen wo wir irgendwie ein kleines projekt in go machen
so max max lernt go
da müssen wir uns nur da müssen wir uns nur irgendein projekt ausdenken
irgendwas kleines was wir machen können sinnvolles was macht das
multis reading das machen wir morgen im stream ich bin in einer halben stunde
bin ich weg oder 35 minuten bin ich weg max lernt go das schreibe ich mir mal auf
als stream thema dann machen wir irgendwas kleines wir müssen uns nur
halt überlegen was web surfer in godi irgendwas irgendwas irgendwas kleines
übersichtliches vielleicht irgendwas was von irgendwas von von irgendwelchen
webseiten was raus passt oder oder wir bauen unser pepega board nach in go was
hältst du von hyper wie als alternative zu forever virtual box für nix das
letzte mal wo ich bei hyper wie geguckt hat hatten die kein ordentliches usb
passthrough kein ordentliche 3d beschleunigung und ich glaube noch nicht
mehr ordentlich sound falls sich jemand damit auskennt kann er mir jetzt ja an
der stelle mal sagen ob das immer noch so ist aber das letzte mal war hyper wie
zur desktop virtualisierung jetzt nicht sonderlich toll geeignet die und der
mit der wett war wirklich schlecht
also das letzte mal wie gesagt durch mein paar wie angeguckt hat hat sich nicht
als alternative auf dem desktop geeignet auf dem windows server mit
irgendwelchen liegungssystemen oder so drauf vielleicht habe ich aber kein
anwendungszweck richtig für
und anscheinend weiß das vorne auch keiner ich denke mal das wird in hyper
wie immer nicht richtig funktionieren virtual box ist eine gute alternative
für desktop virtualisierung ich persönlich finde die das handling vor
immer workstation und das gesamtpaket ein bisschen schöner als in virtual box
allerdings ist virtual box wenn man halt wenn man nichts bezahlen will oder wenn
man ihr wisst schon machen will also sich keine nummer irgendwo raussuchen
will dann ist virtual box natürlich auch eine gute alternative ich habe vor
immer workstation mal gekauft als es das in irgendeiner aktion gab bei vmwär
ist schon ein bisschen her und das hat sich gelohnt
vor immer workstation ist wirklich ist wirklich nice
ja hardware beschleunigung beziehungsweise 3d beschleunigung ist ein
bisschen problematisch wisst ihr was mir was mir richtig fehlt in desktop
virtualisierungslösung das ist dass der hardware zwei dass der video decoder von
der grafikkarte durchgereicht werden kann das fehlt mir wirklich wenn du in
der vm wenn du in der vm und youtube video startest braucht es halt extreme
ressourcen wirklich massig ressourcen erst mal auf guckt euch mal an
drum ist meine cpu auslastung das war mir mal mein battlefield fazit video an in
der vm und stellen es mal hoch auf 4k weiß ob für k und ihr seht huge lag
ja es x ja auf dem es x geht das auf dem es x kann es natürlich gpu passt
zu machen das bringt mir aber halt auf dem desktop nix
also wir haben da schon ordentlich cpu auslastung und auf dem desktop habe ich
cpu auslastung also unter windows habe ich cpu auslastung von drei prozent oder
so dass das fehlt mir wirklich noch in in den vms vielleicht schaffen sie es
ja irgendwie dass man von den vms auf den hardware decoder von der grafikkarte
zugreifen kann das wäre sehr sehr nice also das wäre hyper nice
wie geht es meiner kogeek steckdose die ist die drei dinger liegen immer noch
im karton neben mir ich habe sie noch nirgends wofür angeschlossen aber die
erste kogeek steckdose kommt an mein 3d drucker da kommt nämlich der 3d drucker
dran und der raspberry kommt an den usb eventuell eventuell auch noch irgendwie
ein bisschen anderes was ich da in den in die abstellkammer stellen will
hast du dir eine neue katze geholt ja ich habe jetzt hier doch aber ist chica am
start ich hatte ja pech mit mit meinen katzen die erste ist mehr ist ja vor
drei jahren oder so gestorben und da hatte ich eine andere zwischendurch
zwar die hier also das hier war ja meine erste die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich noch
aus paar videos so der hat sehr streng geguckt danach hatte ich ja hier barbie
die hat die habt nicht ich so genannt die hat die ehemalige hersteller hersteller
alter die ehemalige besitzerin hatte die so genannt war die hier war die schwarze
das war barbie barbie war krank die hat es leider nur ein halbes jahr oder so
geschafft bei mir und jetzt habe ich seit einem halben jahr oder so habe ich
hier chica
das ist der schrank hinter mir hier hinter mir hinter meinem schräg hinter
meinem schreibtisch so das heißt die klotz mich gerade an also das ist jetzt
nicht live aber wenn sie da liegt klotz sie mich gerade an hier unten drunter ist
übrigens meine 15 jahre ct sammlung ist alles komplett voller ct ist muss ich
eigentlich mal wegschmeißen bringt überhaupt nichts aufzuheben
max siehst mit einer freundin aus auch wieder das thema aus bei aus der letzten
sache ist ja nicht wirklich was geworden ob es noch mal zu sagen weiß
doch ich mag keine menschen das ist mein problem
ja knerbeer ins batman aber schicko ist auch lieb schicko wir haben schicko ja
auch aus dem tierheim und die hat sich gefreut dass er rauskommt
nur 690 ja man muss prioritäten setzen
ich wünsche mir ein super fresh super refresh vom garten stellsten
ja da muss es erst mal winter werden
weil garten stells geht ja eigentlich nur im winter kann man kondome eigentlich
auch bei aliexpress bestellen ich will jetzt nicht danach suchen weil wer weiß
was man dann da findet ich weiß aber halt nicht ob man das bei aliexpress
bestellen möchte mal auto vervollständigen und gucken
okay ja ja natürlich natürlich kommt auch bei aliexpress war ja klar aber ich
glaube das ist so eine der sachen zusammen mit batterien und akkus die ich
eher und unterwäsche die ich eher nicht bei aliexpress bestellen würde
ja das funktioniert leider nicht mit dem durchreichen in
ein vor allem der workstation nach s is mist
Ja, mit Kondom von AliExpress, da funktioniert die Forstpflanzung mit Sicherheit.
Zwar ungewollt, aber sie funktioniert.
Lötstation bei Ali, ja, das wäre natürlich eine Sache, die würde ich mir holen bei AliExpress.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, ich bin mit meiner Lötstation sehr zufrieden.
Das Ding, sehr gutes Teil, sehr gutes Teil, beste, kann man warten, bis man ein Angebot
ist, das schöne daran ist, das ist ein ziemlich kleiner Lötkolben und das Kabel ist sehr
flexibel, also man kann damit und man kann die Spitzen wechseln, das heißt man ist damit
wirklich auch für kleine Sachen gewappnet.
Wie hast du das eigentlich umgesetzt, dass du Linux und Windows parallel einsetzen kannst?
Ganz einfach, Windows installiert und dann Forever Workstation installiert, in der Linux
läuft.
Auf den zweiten Desktop gemacht und dann einfach dazwischen umschalten.
Also eigentlich, VirtualBox geht auch, genau, VirtualBox geht auch, klar.
Es geht wahrscheinlich VirtualPC oder so, was es früher mal gab auch oder Hyper-V geht
wahrscheinlich auch oder es gibt es sonst noch so, gibt es noch sonst nennenswerte Virtualisierung
für Windows.
Ja, Flo690, da muss ich dir zum Teil Recht geben, hat geschrieben, es gibt einfach zu
wenig Frauen in der IT, aber ich denke, es liegt auch mit daran, dass der Bereich einfach
nicht so viele Mädels interessiert und man muss ja nicht auf Teufel kommen raus, jetzt
irgendwie mit Frauenquote anfangen oder so, ich meine, man muss ja keinen dazu zwingen,
wenn er nicht will.
Man sollte es jedem erlauben, wenn er möchte, das zu tun, aber man muss ja nicht zwangsläufig
da unbedingt Mädels hinsetzen, wenn sie nicht wollen.
Und die letzten Jahre sind es ja auch schon mehr geworden, also ich denke auch, dass es
jetzt im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr Mädels in der IT werden, aber anteilmäßig gehe
ich mal von aus, in so klassischen IT-Berufen werden es immer mehr Männer geben wie Mädels,
das ist genauso, wie wenn du irgendwo dann bei Design oder so was guckst, oder guck mal,
wenn ich bei uns beispielsweise in die Personalabteilung gucke, 90% Mädels, guckst du bei uns in die
Softwareentwicklung Java, 90% Typen, guckst du bei uns, keine Ahnung, bei Administration,
90% Typen, guckst du bei IOS-Programmierern, 70% Mädels, das kommt einfach auf den Bereich
an.
Das hat mich ja auch überrascht, dass wir so viele Mädels haben als App-Entwickler,
aber das ist einfach diese Designgeschichte scheint mehr anzusprechen, als es Java zum
Beispiel.
Und wie gesagt, ich denke, man muss da nicht auf Teufel kommen raus, überall Mädels hinsetzen,
wenn sie gar nicht wollen.
Wenn sie wollen, sollte man ihnen die Möglichkeiten geben, aber wenn sie nicht wollen, man muss
ja keinen dazu zwingen, es soll jeder machen, was er will.
Aber ich darf ja da eh gar nichts dazu sagen, weil ich bin ja nicht nur weiß, ich bin ja
auch noch männlich und ich bin, wie nennt man das, wenn man, wenn man quasi, na normal
darf man ja nicht sagen, cis, genau cis heißt es, bin ja weiß, männlich, fast 35, privilegiert,
was auch immer, ich darf ja dazu gar nichts sagen, ich bin ja quasi fast der Teufel in
Person, was ich dazu sage, ist eh vollkommen egal, 35 ist alt genug, ist alt genug dafür,
dass man quasi, wie sagen sie immer, Patriarch oder so, keine Ahnung, ich bin heute einfach
alle so viel rum mit dieser Geschichte, ich sag's seit Jahren schon, ich hab auch schon
ein paar Videos drüber gemacht über dieses Thema, als das noch nicht so angesagt war,
ich bin einfach der Ansicht, man sollte wirklich jedem erlauben, das zu machen, was er machen
will, aber man sollte keine Leute irgendwo hinträngen, nur weil man sagt, ey, wir möchten
da jetzt ne 50-50-Quote haben und das ist kompletter sinnlos, lasst die Leute machen, was sie wollen
und vielleicht dauert's in manchen Berufen noch ne Weile, bis es mehr Mädels interessiert
und vielleicht gibt's auch einfach Berufe, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass es in
beide Richtungen was gibt, wo es nie 50-50 sein wird.
Es gibt so klassische Dinger, wenn du beispielsweise mal irgendwie guck in irgendein Design oder
in irgendein Kunst, bei irgendwie Kunst oder guck dir irgendwelche Krankenpflegerbetreuung,
Kindergarten, irgendwas in der Richtung an, ja, da gibt's auch Männer, aber die sind
doch in der Unterzahl, Zyklonschwimmer, ach was, ey, man sollte die Leute einfach machen
lassen, was man will und das ist auch so ein Problem, was alle, also was viele, hab ich
zumindest den Eindruck, so Verfechter, wo die ein Problem damit haben.
Die sagen zwar, die Welt soll offen für alles sein, aber sie akzeptieren das nicht, also
jeder soll super tolerant sein, allerdings nur, wie sie das sehen, sie sind nicht wirklich
tolerant, wenn einer was anders sieht als sie, da gibt's ganz viele Leute in der Richtung
davon in letzter Zeit, das ist der Wahnsinn, eigentlich könnte man einfach mal die Kirche
im Dorf lassen und wirklich jeden einfach seinen Scheiß machen lassen, man sollte wirklich
jeden seinen Scheiß machen lassen und man muss, ich finde das bescheuertste, was man
machen kann, ist, irgendwelche Quoten einführen, was nicht der Interessenslage entspricht.
Mal angenommen, du hast irgendwelche Bereiche, wo es, nehmt man irgendwie einen Ausbildungsberuf
oder einen Studienberuf, wo du 90% Männer hast, 10% Frauen, oder anderes, wo 90% Frauen
und 10% Männer, warum sollte man dann zwangsläufig sagen, nein, wir brauchen jetzt 50-50, wie
soll das überhaupt funktionieren, wenn man 90-10 in der Ausbildung hat?
Und außerdem geht es bei sowas ja immer, oder sollte es eigentlich nicht darum gehen,
dass jemand, nur weil er männlich ist oder weiblich ist oder sonst was ist, quasi mehr
Geld, bessere Positionen oder sonst was kriegt, weil ich meine, was ist das für eine Gleichberechtigung?
Gleichberechtigung würde ja eigentlich heißen, wenn du gleich gut bist oder das Gleiche kannst
und die gleiche Position begleitest, dann solltest du selbstverständlich das Gleiche
kriegen, aber du solltest nicht diese Position kriegen, nur weil du männlich, weiblich,
sonst was bist.
Du solltest diese Person kriegen, du solltest diese Position kriegen, weil du einfach qualifiziert
bist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was daran so kompliziert ist, warum da so ein Riesenaktrum gemacht wird
in den letzten paar Jahren, ja stimmt, Witze darfst du auch nicht machen, ich habe mal mit
dem Friseur zusammen live streamed und da haben wir ein paar Schwulenwitze gemacht und ich
meine, wenn einer Schwulenwitze machen darf, dann noch der Friseur, oder?
Und da hatten wir gleich schon wieder welche im Chat, die sich übertrieben darüber aufgeregt
haben, dass wir ja Schwulenwitze machen würden, der Fabian hat irgendwas über, er hat irgendeinen
Spruch gebracht, so nach dem Motto Blablabla, Homo Fürst, noch was, und da hatten wir gleich
einen im Chat, der sich da übelst draufgeregt hat, also du musst dir mal überlegen, wo
wir schon sind, du darfst als Schwuler 2019 nicht mal Witze über Schwule machen, the
fuck, vor allem warum nicht, warum darfst du nicht als, und auch viel schlimmer, warum
darfst du nicht als Nicht-Schwuler Witze über Schwule machen und warum dürfen die
Schwule Witze, warum, warum, warum ist man wegen jedem Scheiß immer so angepisst, man
sollte doch nicht davon ausgehen, dass, nur weil man selbst der Meinung ist, dass was
nicht stimmt, dass man das jedes Mal laut schreiend der restlichen Welt mitteilen muss
und dann noch die Erwartung hat, die restliche Welt interessiert sich auch für das was man
denkt, es ist ja okay, wenn man sich angegriffen fühlt, es ist ja auch vollkommen, es ist auch
das Recht eines jeden, ja, sich von irgendwas angegriffen zu fühlen, ist ja auch in Ordnung,
da darfst du dich dann auch dazu äußern, aber man sollte nicht davon ausgehen, dass
sich dann automatisch die ganze Welt dafür interessieren muss, dass man jetzt angepisst
ist, so, das nimmt ja mittlerweile Ausmaße an, könnt ihr euch noch an Dings erinnern,
könnt ihr euch Dings hier an, an Humongous, könnt ihr euch noch an Humongous erinnern,
Alter ey, die spinnen alle, die spinnen wirklich alle, könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern,
Humongous, aber mir hat unter dem Video auch schon mal einer erzählt, als ich voll der
Nazi wäre, weil ich hab irgendjemand zitiert, ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich genau zitiert
hab, irgendein der nen Spruch gebracht hat, wo nen Wort drinne vorkommt, was auch Rechte
verwenden, ich weiß gar nicht mal was es für nen Wort war, und ich hab das ja nur zitiert
und der selbst hat es ja quasi auch einfach nur nen Wort, das war jetzt für mich, ich
kann mich da nicht mehr dran, ich weiß nicht mal was es für ein Wort gewesen ist, es ist
eigentlich kein Wort, wo du sofort irgendwie an irgendwelche Nazis und Rechte denkst, ja,
guter Mensch, nee, nee, nee, es war irgendwas anderes, ich weiß nicht was es war, so und
der hat es eigentlich auch nur benutzt, ohne dass es ihm überhaupt darum ging und ich hab's
nur zitiert, was der, was der gesagt hat, ja, also ich hab schon mal gar nichts in dieser
Richtung, aber irgendjemand hat einfach das Video angehört, dieses Wort gehört und war
komplett aus dem Kontext heraus instant übelst getriggert. Ich find man sollte alles ein
bisschen mit, ein bisschen weniger, ein bisschen weniger verbissen sehen, weil gerade die Hardcore
dieser Sachen, die sehen die Sachen meistens mit Abstand am verbissensten und sind superfeindlich
allen gegenüber eingestellt, die nicht exakt ihre Meinung teilen. Wenn man sich das auf
Twitter anguckt, es ist ja, wir sind ja schon so weit, dass Frauen von Feministinnen beleidigt
werden, weil sie nicht ihre Ansichten teilen. Kann nicht jeder seine Ansicht haben, was
er will. Ist das heute eigentlich der produktives Team, ja wir haben schon eingekauft, aber es
kann doch eigentlich jeder seine Ansicht haben, was er will und wenn es ihm nicht passt, darf
er da auch was zu sagen, aber er muss nicht davon ausgehen, dass sich die ganze Welt auf
einmal dafür interessiert. Es hat sich, ich hab doch mal ein Video drüber aufgenommen,
was drum ging, ähm, über weibliche E-Sport-Pros, mit ner Mädels zusammen. Ist doch gar nicht
so lang her, das Video. Und da haben sich auch welche in den Kommentaren drüber aufgeregt.
Und dabei hat sie gesagt im Video, das hab ich natürlich bei ich gesagt, sie hat im
Video gesagt, dass, öhm, oftmals die Mädels, ich versuch das jetzt mal so sinngemäß zu
zitieren, oftmals die Mädels selbst dran schuld sind, ähm, weil sie andere Prioritäten
haben. Das kommt von ner Frau, ja, das hab nicht ich gesagt im Video. Sie hat im Video
gesagt, sie denkt, dass es so wenige Mädels quasi im E-Sport gibt, weil Frauen oftmals
andere Prioritäten haben. Daran ist doch überhaupt nichts Schlimmes auszusetzen. Sie hat wahrscheinlich
damit auch genau recht. Das wird auch der Grund sein, warum es so wenig Mädels im E-Sport
gibt, die richtig gut sind. Wenn man einfach andere Prioritäten hat, dann macht man einfach
was anderes. Und sitzt nicht 12 Stunden vorm Rechner und cry in irgendeinem Game. Das macht
man dann nicht. Das ist ab-, das ist in Ordnung. Aber dann muss man auch keine, keine E-Sport-Frauenquote
einführen, wenn es die Leute nicht von sich aus wollen. Wozu? Die ganzen Mäd-, die ganzen
weiblichen E-Sport-Teams. Zum größten, es gibt Ausnahmen, es gibt ein paar. In Hearthstone
gibt es, glaub ich, ein paar recht gute Mädels. In Overwatch gibt es ein ganz gutes Mädel,
also es ist nicht so, dass es keine gibt, aber die sind dann auch gut, weil sie halt eben
das Spiel ordentlich cryen. Die sind nicht gut, weil sie da wegen irgendeiner Frauenquote
hingesetzt wurden, sondern weil sie gut sind. Ja, und die ganzen-, die ganzen Female-, Female-Teams,
die viele Orgas haben, sind eigentlich komplett entgegen diesem ganzen Feminismuszeug, sind
die meisten Female-Teams, die Orgas haben, nicht dafür da, dass die irgendwie kompetitiv
spielen in irgendeiner Liga oder vielleicht auch in der Mädelsliga spielen oder so, sondern
die sind einzig und allein als Werbefigur, als Werbezweck in dieser Orga. Du kannst
ein Female-CS-Team machen und du kriegst teilweise Verträge, weil du ein Female-CS-Team bist,
nicht weil du ein gutes Female-CS-Team bist. Und das ist das nicht eigentlich komplett
kontraproduktiv, wenn man sagen will, hey, wir möchten zeigen, dass auch Mädels gut
spielen können und dann kriegt man als CS-Team oder als LoL-Team, als Dota-, was auch immer,
als Female-Only-Team kriegt man nur den Vertrag, weil man Female ist und nicht, weil man gut
ist. Das ist eigentlich genau das Umgedrehte von dem, was man eigentlich haben will. Gut,
was auch immer, also. Kann man, kann ich, kann ich ewig, kann ich ewig erzählen. Aber
ich darf hier eh nix sagen. Ich darf hier eh nix sagen. Weiß, männlich, 35, hetero 6,
das geht ja gar nicht. Ich darf das nicht. Nein. Ich sag das alles nur, weil ich ja,
wie sagen sie immer, ich möchte ja quasi die weiße männliche Dominanz erhalten. Sonst,
das liegt nicht daran, weil ich einfach versuche mal ein bisschen logisch drüber nachzudenken.
Nein, das muss einzig und allein, um weiße männliche Dominanz zu erhalten sein. Das ist,
das ist wirklich, also ich hab echt das Gefühl, das ist aktuell so ein bisschen die Zeit der
Verrückten in allen, in allen Bereichen. Fängt schon, fängt schon mit Tracers Freundin an
im Comic. Wo das nicht etwa gefeiert wird von den Leuten, die sich sonst für diese
Themen stark machen, dass Tracer offiziell eine Freundin hat. Nein! Jetzt wird sich drüber
aufgeregt, dass Tracer eine Freundin hat, weil das ja ein Charakter ist, der offensichtlich
für das männliche Auge geschaffen wurde. Hier hätten sie Saria nehmen sollen, dann
hätten sie sich wieder aufgeregt und nach dem Motto, ah so eine klischeehafte Darstellung,
blablabla. Du kannst das, du kannst das keinem rechts machen. Das wurde eigentlich gekauft,
ähm, USB-Kabel, Micro SD-Karten, Pflanzensensoren, Jumper-Kabel und den anderen Kram haben wir
nicht gefunden. Anzeige jetzt raus. Ich bin ja mal auf die Witcher-Serie gespannt. Die
hat ja auch den übelsten, ähm, Flame abgekriegt von den Fans, weil, äh, wie war das nochmal?
Weil Ciri asiatisch ist in der Serie oder irgendwie sowas. Genau, weil Ciri irgendwie
asiatisch sein soll in der Serie. Irgendwas war da doch mit der Witcher-Serie. Da haben
sie sich auch übertrieben aufgeregt. Das ist auch sowas, was ich an der Stelle nicht
verstehen kann, wo ich sag, ey, lass mal abwarten. Ich mein, okay, ich find's an sich immer nicht
gut, wenn man sich allzu sehr von der Vorlage entfernt, aber wie weit das dann wirklich
fest ist, da sollte man erstmal abwarten und sich den Cast angucken, ob das passt. Ja,
ich kann mir Superman auch nicht wirklich gut als Witcher vorstellen, aber, ey, vielleicht
wird man überrascht. Oder Yennefer ist persisch fast auch immer, aber abwarten, ja, das ist,
das ist, das ist nicht so wild. Sofern das im Geist das Original, so, im Geist so von,
von dem ist, ist das doch in Ordnung. Allerdings, was ich da wiederum bescheuert finde, ist,
wenn man quasi krampfhaft versucht, dann wirklich jede Rolle irgendwie möglichst divers zu
besetzen. Wenn man das macht, wenn man sagt, hey, wir haben, wir haben Leute, die sind
super geeignet für, ähm, irgendwie Ciri zu spielen, vielleicht kann ja sein, dass
man spezielle Voraussetzungen hat, ne, man hat vielleicht schon weiße Haare, man hat
vielleicht schon bisschen irgendwie, was weiß ich, Schwertkampferfahrung, keine Ahnung,
irgendwie sowas, wenn man sagt, ey, da hat man jemand richtig Gutes, sie ist Asiatin,
ist überhaupt kein Problem, soll sie halt Ciri spielen, hat das mit der Vorlage nichts
zu tun, aber sie eignet sich halt richtig gut für. Was ich, was ich, ist mir doch vollkommen
egal, ob, ob, ob Ciri ein Weißbrot ist oder eine Asiatin, ist doch egal. Ob man, ob man
jetzt allerdings sagen muss, hey, wir brauchen, also der Unterschied ist halt dazwischen,
ob man sagt, okay, wir haben jemand geeignet, das passt, ähm, dann ist mir das auch wurscht,
wenn man jetzt natürlich sagt, okay, wir müssen jetzt zwangsläufig auch, auch entgegen der
Vorlage dafür sorgen, dass wir, äh, keine Ahnung, nen, nen, nen, nen, einen schwarzen Geralt haben,
ne, ne Asiatische Ciri, ne Persische Yennefer, das ist dann wieder eine Sache, wo ich mir
sag, okay, man muss ja nicht quasi die Rollen besetzen mit, mit, ähm, wenn man doch keine
Leute dafür hat, wo man einfach nur sagt, hey, wir brauchen möglichst unterschiedlich,
das muss doch nicht sein, wenn man jemand hat, der sich gut dafür eignet, der eben nicht
original der Vorlage entspricht, ist es kein Problem, aber umgedreht muss man es auch nicht
machen. Über das Rüstungs-, ja, über das Rüstungsdesign haben sie sich auch aufgeregt.
Ach, hast du deine App wieder, das ist nice. Wie sieht es eigentlich mit der Witcher Serie aus?
Oh nice, mal gucken. Hallo, Bilder? Ah, IGN. Ja, es ist immer noch eindeutig Superman, aber
er sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen, Alter, was ist das für eine Rüstung? Über das Rüstungsdesign
könnte man sich wirklich aufregen. Das ist die beknackteste Rüstung, die man sich vorstellen
kann, ja. Also ich finde, sich über Rüstungsdesign aufregen ist viel produktiver, sich da drüber
aufzuregen, ob Siri jetzt Asiatin ist oder nicht. Über Rüstungsdesign kann man sich
an der Stelle wirklich aufregen. Das ist total bescheuerte Rüstung. Was bringen denn diese
komischen Nieten hier dran? Also erstens, was, Leder mit Stoff dazwischen? Warum? Wozu?
Das ist komplett sinnlos. Und diese komischen Nieten da oben drauf bringen auch nichts.
Oder meint ihr jetzt, wenn irgendwie das Monster kommt und Geralt beißen will, beißt
es genau auf diese eine Niete da oben drauf? Oh, da haben sie aber schön enge Hose angezogen.
Yennefer, okay, Yennefer. Okay, Siri ist überhaupt nicht Asiatisch. Siri ist Weißbrot, so wie
man das kennt. Also die ganze Aufregung im Vorfeld umsonst gewesen. Und regen sie sich
drüber auf. Natürlich wird es drüber aufgeregt. Aber ich finde das sieht gar nicht so schlecht
aus. Okay, man muss sagen, also die Rüstung finde ich wirklich fail, die sie anhat. Die
Rüstung ist wirklich fail. Und Schwert auf dem Rücken ist im Prinzip auch fail, aber
ich glaube, das hat er in der Vorlage auch so. Wobei das noch irgendwie geht, das kriegt
man wenigstens halbwegs raus so, wobei das schon ein bisschen hoch sein könnte. Aber
ja, okay, dass man sich über das Rüstungsdesign aufregt, kann ich verstehen. Die Leute sind
getriggert, weil nur ein Schwert auf dem Rücken. Die Leute sind wegen jedem Scheiß getriggert.
Aber an sich sieht das doch ganz okay aus. Ich meine, die Hose ist schon verdammt eng,
ja. Das Rüstungsdesign ist absolut sinnlos. Also so eine Rüstung wird kein Mensch anziehen,
der sich schützen will gegen Monster, Krallen, Zähne, sonst was. Komplett nicht funktional,
vor allem mit dem Stoff dazwischen. Und die Nieten bringen halt auch nichts, außer für
die Aerodynamik natürlich, ja. Dafür sieht das Schwert doch ganz brauchbar aus. Tja,
wo kommt es denn raus?
Da steht kein Release-Datum, oder? Late 2019? Das wär cool. Also Late 2019 wär nice. Warum
hat das überhaupt schon eine Bewertung überhaupt? Das kann doch keine Bewertung haben, das ist
nicht mal rausgekommen. What the fuck? Warum hat das eine Bewertung? Eine Bewertung mit
... Warum gibt es dazu eine Bewertung? Das Ding ist ja nicht mal raus. Bewertung in 2k90.
Was Serious Max, hast du... Was war das für eine Frage jetzt, ey. Hast du heute vom Deep
Nude gehört? Deep Fake... Das ist doch nichts Neues. Gibt's doch schon eine Weile. Ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass Deep Fakes die meisten Materialien werden wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Pornvideos sein. Das ist doch immer so. Gibt's eine neue Technik, wofür wird sie als erstes
verwendet, flächendeckend für irgendwelche Pornvideos. Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur?
Ja klar. Keine Ahnung, hab ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Porn bringt die Technik voran. Also insofern, wenn man sich anguckt, was neue Videotechnologien
anbelangt, ist das tatsächlich so. Die ersten Videos waren damals, oder die ersten verbreiteten
Videos waren damals irgendwelche Pornvideos. So die ersten richtigen... Gut, bei DVD ist
nicht so. Allerdings die ersten VR Geschichten. Genau, waren auch irgendwelche Porns. Blu-ray
ist bestimmt genauso, DVD ist bestimmt genauso. Und der größte, oder mit der größte quasi
Content für neue Content auch und regelmäßiger Content und wahrscheinlich auch Geld mit VR
wird gerade bei VR-Porns verdient. Also wenn's danach geht, bringt das die Technik schon
vorwärts. Ich hab mal irgendwo gelesen, dass in diesem
Business wohl irgendeine spanische Firma voll das Monopol hat auf VR-Porns.
Schon ein bisschen her. Die Spanier wissen, wie's geht. Mal gelesen. Ja, so was liest
man. Was sonst? Irgendeine spanische Firma, die auch eigene
Aufnahmetechnik dafür entwickelt hat oder so was.
Wieso kennt sich der Max so gut aus? Wer kennt sich in der heutigen Zeit, der einen
Anschluss hat zumindest nicht damit aus. Ist das so Flo96?
Im Internet kennt sich jeder mit allem aus, das stimmt. Also zumindest erzählen sie das
und ganz wichtig, wenn du im Internet jemanden siehst, der was er anführlich falsch schreibt,
du musst ihn sofort korrigieren. Alles andere geht gar nicht.
Die sind gerade dabei, die wollen so eine VR-Halle bauen, mit selbstentwickeltem Content.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, sobald's da was zu sehen gibt.
Also bei Technik können sie's auf jeden Fall. Dafür kennen die sich gut genug aus.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie allerdings auch die ganze organisatorische Sache und finanzielle
Sache da gestemmt kriegen drumherum. Sollte es da was geben, werd ich auf jeden
Fall mal ein Video davon machen. Was ich halt ganz interessant finde, dass
die eigenen Multiplayer, die wollen irgendwie eigenen VR-Multiplayer-Content für Teams oder
halt für Familien machen. Mal gucken, wie gut das klappt.
Das hab ich auch gelesen letztens. Wieso was soll da draus geworden sein? Wahrscheinlich
funktioniert's. Ne, cheat 1995, das Ding ist noch im Hof.
Und ich teste mal so die Laufzeit mit Batterie. Bisher sieht's gut aus.
Okay Leute, es ist 21 Uhr. Ich muss jetzt Schluss machen, dass ich dann
um 22 Uhr auch normal pennen kann. Wir sehen uns morgen, oder ich sag das jetzt
schon so selbstverständlich, weil ich die letzten Tage immer gestrebt hab.
Ja, wir sehen uns vielleicht morgen. Sicher ist das ja nicht, aber ich bin in letzter
Zeit wirklich ziemlich regelmäßig am Streamen. Ja, machen wir Schluss, wir sehen uns dann.
Bis dann, tschüss, see you.